there's this very popular test online
it's called the political compass test
and basically it scans on two separate
axes from left to right on the x axis it
shows communism and collectivism to
neoliberalism and libertarianism on the
right and then on the y axis it goes
authoritarianism down to anarchism and
libertarianism we'll see how accurate it
is if the scale is correct in any way I
will end up in the in the right
libertarian category I mean that's
obviously where I am I think the
premises of the questions are incredibly
stupid so let's just jump right in
question number one if economic
globalization is inevitable it should
primarily serve humanity rather than the
interests of transnational corporations
did Bernie Sanders write this question
what a stupid ass question seriously
like transnational corporations which
are responsible in through the use of
free-market capitalism for the dramatic
decrease of poverty throughout humanity
are now opposed to humanity so the very
phraseology of the question is idiotic
but since they're asking this I'm just
going to assume that their premise is
wrong and put strongly disagree because
transnational corporations have been a
lot more helpful to humanity than
top-down government induced schemes guy
I'd always support my country whether it
was right or wrong I disagree with that
I disagree with that because what if
your country is terrible no one chooses
his or her country of birth to as
foolish to be proud of it they generally
agree that that it's silly to be proud
of of just where you were born you
should be proud of the country because
the country actually doesn't suck our
race has many superior qualities
compared with other races strongly
disagree because I don't think that
races matter in terms of inherent
quality that's that that's that's
silliness the enemy of my enemy is my
friend well I I disagree with that and
the enemy of my enemy costed me enemy a
military action that defies
international law is sometimes justified
strongly agree international law is a
bunch of crap written by countries that
generally have their own priorities the
UN Security Council includes Russia and
China so yeah I'm gonna go with strongly
disagree or strongly agree on we can
sometimes defy the idiocy of
international law which is an idiotic
construct in the first place there is
now a worrying fusion of information and
entertainment disagree disagree the
reason I say disagree is because there
was always that fusion we just ignored
it until the last five minutes whenever
got mad because conservatives were
suddenly creating news okay the economy
people are ultimately divided more by
class and then nationality strongly
disagree and World War one proved that
that's a bunch of nonsense controlling
inflation is more important than
controlling unemployment I agree with
that
because you can't actually control
unemployment you can only provide the
principles necessary in order for an
economy to flourish the only way to
control unemployment directly would be
through top-down government control and
you could have a horrible economy with
complete employment that was called the
USSR or Cuba or Venezuela until the last
five minutes because corporations cannot
be trusted to voluntarily protect the
environment that require regulation well
I mean I generally agree but I wouldn't
single out corporations there obviously
when it comes to environmental
regulations you do require environmental
regulations you have the tragedy of the
Commons you have the the ability to
regulate externalities from each
according to his ability to each
according to his need is a fundamentally
good idea strongly disagree because need
should not dictate either moral worth or
the morality of the thing that that you
need
it's a sad reflection on our society
that something as basic as drinking
water is now a bottled branded consumer
product strongly disagree why is that
why is that bad I'm confused I mean you
can still get it from the tap like
seriously like if you don't like the
bottled water just don't drink the
bottled water
it seems pretty fantastic that you're
even go to the store and buy basically
whatever you want land shouldn't be a
competitor to be bought and sold
strongly disagree because what would the
alternative be that it would be all
government owned and allocated by the
government it is regrettable that many
personal fortunes are made by people who
simply manipulate money and contribute
nothing to their society again the
premise of that question is so
ridiculous a lot of the time when people
suggest that people are just
manipulating money what they are
actually doing is mitigating risk and
assessing risk and providing capital and
liquidity markets that allow you to go
out and spend on your company on your
business or allow you to have a credit
card for example so I'm gonna go with
disagree on that one
maybe strongly disagree protectionism is
sometimes it necessary in trade agree
but only for national security reasons
so maybe disagree maybe I'll put
disagree because it's generally not
necessary in trade it's only necessary
for national security reasons it's not
necessary for economic reasons the only
social responsibility of a company
should be to deliver a profit to its
shareholders agree I mean agree that's
what a company is designed to do it
designed to provide a profit to its
general holders and that has a bunch of
ancillary benefits it's not designed for
employment it's not designed for
redistribution the rich are too highly
taxed strongly agree and by the way I
agreed with this when I was making 50 60
grand a year of course the rich are too
highly taxed on a net basis the the rich
are paying for nearly everything in the
country right now via taxation those
with the ability to pay should have
access to higher standards of medical
care
well again the phraseology of the
question is so ass-backwards because
again the question isn't whether those
with the ability to pay should have
access to higher standards of medical
care the question is whether a system
that allows people to pay for better
medical care also allows people who are
poor to get better medical care meaning
then when rich people pay more for
medical care where do you think that
money goes it goes into the medical
system it is then reinvested in drug
development reinvested in medical
innovation so the answer is agree but
again like you can tell who wrote these
questions I mean these questions are
obviously written by people or very much
of the political left government should
penalize businesses that mislead the
public agree but it depends on what you
mean by mislead the public obviously you
don't actually have to have the
government penalize those businesses
that's fraud I mean if they defraud
somebody you can have a tort suit on
that basis by genuine free market
requires restrictions on the ability of
predator multinationals to create
monopolies I'm going to say disagree
only in the sense that a natural
monopoly is nearly impossible it is very
difficult to establish a natural
monopoly the typical way that monopolies
are generated is because governments
have approved them is because
governments have sponsored the
monopolies the freer of the market the
freer the people strongly agree ok next
page abortion when the woman's life is
not threatened it should always be
illegal strongly agree all authority
should be questioned agree I mean I
think that we should always ask the
basis for the authority an eye for an
eye and a tooth for a tooth
what one of the great missin all of
biblical history is the notion that an
eye for an eye and a tooth for a tooth
is meant to be taken literally means
there's entire swath of the Talmud
dedicated to discussing the fact that
this is meant in terms of monetary
pricing that the cost of an eye should
be repaid by compensatory damages an eye
for an eye and tooth for a tooth
disagree taxpayers should not be
expected to prop up any theaters or
museums that cannot survive on a
commercial basis agree
that doesn't mean you can't have a
non-profit most museums are run on a
non-profit basis schools should not make
a classroom attendance compulsory agree
but they should make it that parents are
truant if they do not pass certain
educational standards for their children
for the welfare of kids but but
suggesting that we're going to force you
to send your kids to a public school as
opposed to homeschooling that's why the
question is a little bit vague like what
kind of classroom attendants were
talking homeschooling are talking
publics going all people have their
rights but it is better for all of us
the different sorts of people should
keep to their own kind again the way
this is phrased is so ridiculous well
what does that mean different sorts of
people should keep to their own kind
like I think that people should marry
people who have similar values but I
don't know if think if I kind they mean
ethnicity or race in which case
completely disagree so it completely
depends on what they mean by the
question there's inherent vagary to
these questions and I understand that
these questions are designed to elicit
responses that are quote unquote racist
so they can label you conservative for
being racist I understand that's what
they're doing here but the questions are
deliberately written in vague fashion to
elicit those responses so knowing what
they want I'm gonna go strongly disagree
good parents sometimes have to spank
their children I generally have sugar at
that I'm not in favor of spanking and I
don't spank my kids it's natural for
children to keep some secrets from their
parents I mean I agree that it is
natural it is also wrong as a general
matter so I don't know what they're
going for there I'll say agree on
whether it's natural but I like that the
survey immediately seems to identify
natural with morally correct which of
course is silly possessing marijuana for
personal use should not be a criminal
offense agree the prime function of
schooling should be to equip the future
generation to find jobs strongly agree
and the moral education is generally the
the preserve of the parents people with
serious inheritable disabilities should
not be allowed to reproduce strongly
disagree I'm not that we're calling that
the Woodrow Wilson eugenicist their most
important thing for children to learn is
to accept discipline obviously disagree
it's an important thing for kids to
accept discipline because they don't
know things because they're kids it is
not the most important thing for
children the most important thing for
children is to be taken seriously and
develop actual rational modes of thought
there are no savage and civilized people
there are only different cultures well
again the way this is phrased is
ridiculous by saying people's what they
are now implying is that if you say that
there is a uncivilized culture that you
are labeling a people meaning an
ethnicity or a race so the
phraseology of the question is asinine
but if we rephrase the question this is
the question I'll answer so now it's
clear there are no savage and civilized
cultures there are only different
cultures strongly disagree obviously
that's not true there are some cultures
that suck and if you don't believe me
check out the Taliban those who are able
to work and refused the opportunity
should not expect society's support
strongly agree when you are troubled
it's better not to think about it but to
keep busy with more cheerful things
generally agree it's better I mean
wallowing in things is not usually a
great solution first-generation
immigrants can never be fully integrated
within their in a country disagree
what's good for the most successful
corporations is always ultimately good
for all of us disagree because many
successful corporations are looking for
government handouts or bailouts no
broadcasting institution however
independence its content should receive
public funding strongly agree our civil
liberties are being excessively curbed
in the name of counter terrorism in the
United States I'm gonna go slightly
disagree but I'm kind of torn on this
one I'm like between a Grandison Rihanna
Slee a significant advantage of a
one-party state is that it avoids all
the arguments that delay progress in a
democratic political system strongly
disagree when party states are garbage
although the electronic age makes
official surveillance easier only
wrongdoers need to be worried at
disagree the death penalty should be an
option for the most serious crimes that
strongly agree in a civilized society
one must always have people above to be
obeyed and people below to be commanded
strongly disagree
abstract art that doesn't represent
anything shouldn't be considered art at
all agree I mean like if you give me a
blank canvas and tell me that it's art
you're an idiot
in criminal justice punishment should be
more important than rehabilitation agree
although there is a third purpose to
criminal justice which is not punishment
and not rehabilitation it's also keeping
criminals off the streets it's a waste
of time to try to rehabilitate some
criminals strongly agree obviously there
are recidivism rates that are extremely
high the business person and
manufacturer are more important than the
writer and the artists disagree many
times the writer and the artist are the
font of ideas but you know the market
decides all of that I'm not gonna decide
who's more important who's less
important and anybody who tries to on
one end or the other end is doing the
wrong thing mothers may have careers but
their first duty is to be homemakers
notice they don't ask the question about
fathers by the way they only asked the
question about mothers I'm gonna say
agree but only because I think that if
they're a question that said fathers may
have careers but their first duty is to
be homemakers I would also
they agree meaning that my first duty is
to be a father and to be a husband I
mean my second duty is to have a job in
support of that so I'm only gonna say
agree because I hold the exact same
thing for men
I understand again these questions are
designed to elicit the notion that if
you're in favor of women who have
children putting their children first
it's because you're a sexist but as I
say if the question we're about fathers
I'll give it exactly the same answer
multinational companies are unethically
exploiting the plant genetic resources
of developing countries Oh GMOs no
disagree making peace with the
establishment is an important aspect of
maturity disagree um depends what the
establishment is okay there's about
religion I guess astrology accurately
explains many things strongly disagree
you cannot be moral without being
religious disagree I don't think you can
build a fully moral system based on
objective morality on pure subjectivism
but you can certainly be moral without
being religious charity is better than
social securities and means of helping
the genuinely disadvantaged agree some
people are naturally unlucky I don't
know what that means I mean obviously
some people are born with certain
disadvantages so obviously that's true
if you mean do I think that there are
certain people who are just destined to
walk into manhole cover isn't and then
no so I think everybody is born with an
equal level of privilege and luckiness
know so I guess I'll say I agree it is
important that my child's school
instills religious values strongly agree
sex outside marriage is usually immoral
strongly agree a same-sex couple in a
stable loving relationship should not be
excluded from the possibility of child
adoption so the answer is agree but it
depends on the alternative I have a sort
of hierarchy in terms of adoption if
you're talking about a stable loving
heterosexual couple versus a stable
loving same-sex couple I'll take the
heterosexual couple because I don't
think that mothers and fathers play the
same role if you're talking about a
stable loving same-sex couple verses in
orphanage where kids are being ignored
then obviously I think that same-sex
couples should be able to adopt
pornography depicting consenting adults
should be legal for the adult population
it depends who is doing the regulation
so my general answer is disagree I don't
think that it should be legal but I
think that it's very difficult to draw
regulation that is not too heavy-handed
in this area I don't think you have a
right to pornography though I don't
think
an inherent right to pornography what
goes on in a private bedroom between
consenting adults is no business of the
state
strongly agree no one can feel naturally
homosexual strongly disagree and again
this all these questions are designed to
elicit particular responses so the idea
is that if you're religious and if
you're conservative then what just gonna
list me as a libertarian you'll say you
can believe that homosexual activity is
sinful on a biblical religious level and
still believe that people have natural
desires to do things that are that are
biblically sinful I mean that happens
all the time these days open us about
sex has gone too far strongly agree and
if you disagree it's because I'm not
sure you're a sentient human the only
question here that I'm kind of torn on
is the pornography question and that's
only because it's a question of
gradation I'm really wavering between
disagree and agree on legality for the
adult population because again is it
harming third parties generally no I
guess I'll say agree it should be legal
for the adult population I'm really
really torn it's on a moral level
obviously I think pornography is one of
the great evils in our society on a
legal level do I think that the
government has the capacity to to
regulate it if you're talking federally
no locally yes but I think that's true
of a lot of things so they don't
actually make clear where the illegality
is coming from all right let's see where
I stand it says that I am right
libertarian right which is true it says
that I'm 6.13 on the economic right and
on the libertarian versus authoritarian
score I am slightly more libertarian I'm
negative 0.72 on that score so that
would put me closer to like Milton
Friedman territory the scale itself is
really stupid
the reason the scale itself is really
stupid and I mean is because I'm looking
at the examples that they give they put
Hitler and Thatcher in the same category
they say that they are authoritarian
right Adolf Hitler and Margaret Thatcher
which makes no sense and is full-scale
idiotic they have Stalin in the left
authoritarian category and they have
Hitler in the right authoritarian
category and Thatcher in the right
authoritarianism encino the questions
are designed to elicit particular
responses I just don't think that this
is a particularly accurate score I think
the outcome of where I am on the scale
is fairly accurate although I would say
that I'm kind of shocked that
place me as more libertarian like based
on based on what would be the question
but there you have it
I've gone through this thing at great
length with you and hope you enjoy